foreign
people of the internet we are live and
we've got a Friday Florida Freedom
Extravaganza I couldn't think of an f
word that worked with Extravaganza uh
joining me today is the co-host of the
nationally syndicated radio show clay
and buck buck Sexton a Fox News and New
York Post columnist Carol Markowitz and
a former NYPD officer and political
commentator John cardillo Buck Carol
John good to see you guys we all took a
private flight up to Tallahassee I was
in a cockpit and John handed me
champagne we're all still here so pretty
uh pretty good start to the week
wouldn't you say we made it it started a
week
uh
I did not know I did not know that as
the co-pilot your whole situation over
there is basically exactly what the main
pilot has so had he had a medical
condition or episode or something I I
was gonna take us home which is very
scary
gotta land the plane and really not to
you if in fact and this was just so it
was clear this is one of those you know
yeah it was one of those blades which
always feels a little more I don't know
to me but it was a it was a little
terrified I was on that plane it was a
little prop plane but we made it to
Tallahassee and of course the reason we
were in Tallahassee we weren't just
going for nothing uh was for governor
Ron desantis's inauguration uh and the
ball and a couple other events that were
going there so let's let's start with
that because I think as everyone
watching this knows uh all four four of
us are Floridians three of us uh Buck
Carol and I are new Floridians John's
been here for about 20 years so we got
to give the shout out to the OG uh but
good things are happening down in
Florida and that's in strong contrast to
just sort of the Endless dysfunction
that is happening uh in DC as we speak
at this very moment so let's throw to
just a little bit of Governor desantis's
inauguration speech
this bizarre but prevalent ideology that
permeates these policy measures
purports to act in the name of justice
for the marginalized but it frowns upon
American institutions it rejects Merit
and achievement and it Advocates
identity essentialism
we reject this woke ideology
we seek normalcy not philosophical
lunacy we will not allow reality facts
and Truth to become optional we will
never surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die
so that was the big Applause line of the
whole thing John I want to start with
you since yeah you've you've been here
the longest so you know you helped pave
the road for us crazy refugees normalcy
competency reality I mean nothing he
said up there should be extraordinary
and yet it is and we're all lucky enough
to be a little part of it
look I mean Florida's never really been
until Ron DeSantis a truly conservative
State sure we voted red but uh our state
senate has been pretty Squishy in terms
of the Rhinos I mean there was a Senate
President a while back woman named Anna
Terra Flores from Miami she was a State
Rep she invited moms to man Michael
Bloomberg's gun grabbers in and was
giddy and smiling and taking photos with
them and taking their money but the
Santas grew up in Florida and he watched
the state become purple and creeped
toward blue we almost had Andrew Gillum
as Governor thank God the status won and
DeSantis just literally a meth addict
literally literally a meth addict
literally a meth addict write a lot
about it but the sadness has really
really changed the game in this state
he's gone full bore with conservative
Common Sense policies and we were all
saying this on the plane I think I was
saying this Carol and her husband
what the Santa has done is not complex
you just govern through the lens of the
Constitution of your state and the
Constitution the United States of
America you do what he said you put
Common Sense over this philosophical
nonsense and you wind up with a really
conservative agenda that people love I
mean look we picked up a congressional
seat New York lost one we're doing
something right
Buck I think you're the newest here in
Florida just a couple months in if I'm
not mistaken uh it's working down here
huh
look there's a reason why I think the
number is over 300 000 uh left New York
my home state in in the last year uh and
so not all of them moved to Florida but
a huge portion of them did uh Florida
Texas Tennessee these are all states
where you have more freedom where you
have more sanity in general at the state
government level uh you do have good
cities in all of those States so you
know one of the challenges I think in a
lot of the red States is you go okay
well you know if you if you move to
Montana
you know which isn't even that red as a
state by the way
um but you're not really going to be
able to have a any kind of a city to
live in whereas here we got Miami
obviously Nashville and Tennessee and
then Dallas slash Houston slash well
Austin's a little too commy but I do
love it anyway that's the problem like I
want anarchists covered in tattoos
making my latte because they're really
good at it like so I have to find that
that mix between constitutional freedom
and sane government and you know police
that are are backed up
you are definitely you are definitely
not spending enough time in Miami
because if you get like a really
anti-communist Cuban to make you a
cafecito forget your latte my friend oh
no it's fantastic I mean when you call
someone a Kami here which I've been
doing for years by the way it it is gets
people fired up they really don't they
know what communism actually is and so
they really don't like it here
um I think that this is this is the
after effective covid that many of us
talked about for a while I mean Carol
weren't you were you on that
um remember when they had the thing was
like a big phone call where everyone
could clubhouse right we did like a club
were you on that Clubhouse and they're
all these they're all these dead enders
in New York and there and there was sort
of this attitude like none of you were
gonna leave
actually that's not what ended up
happening so I think there's good
reasons why
um and I Carol had a line that really
stuck with me I've told this many times
because it was what I was feeling too in
the Communist Enclave of of Manhattan
um during kovid which was I at one point
you cross over from being mad at the
people in charge to being mad at the
people who vote for these people and and
keep they say and once that happens once
you can't respect your neighbors enough
to stop being crazy you gotta go I think
that's an action that's a really great
Point Carol I'm glad that buck brought
it up because that's what I was feeling
in La I I obviously was frustrated with
Newsom and Garcetti and these ridiculous
bureaucrats but then and I would go to
the supermarket and I was angry at
random people and that was part of the
transition you also went to uh during
the day I think between the inauguration
and the and the ball you went to a it
was like a parents conference or a
mother's conference and I'm guessing it
was just more sanity right like not just
hardcore conservative political thought
but just basic sanity
right so I'm big on anniversaries and
the inauguration day was my one year
anniversary of living in Florida and
today obviously January 6th is a huge
anniversary of one year of us meeting
Governor DeSantis
was that on January 6th that was that
was a year ago today when we went up
there we go today
on Dave and I and some other people were
at the governor's mansion meeting the
governor for the first time and I just
remember thinking that night that like
he has a lot of things at stake very
similar to me the fact that he has small
children it shows it really shows he has
to fight for a certain education system
that they're going to grow up in he has
to um you know really just fight for a
society that they're going to live in I
think it's so important to him for you
know very similar reasons as it is to me
and just moving to Florida the comfort
that I feel with my kids like I just I
worry about what they're getting in
school so much less I worry about just
general indoctrination someone less it's
it's really been a weight lifted off of
me I was not sleeping like towards the
end of our New York's day because of
those you know insane neighbors who I
just saw pushing this ever crazier
agenda
all right well I don't want to rain on
everybody's parade but we're going to
show you a video clip now I did not have
my producers send this to you before the
show but this is a small portion of Rod
desantis's speech and when I was
listening to it I thought I had heard
this somewhere else this could burst
into a massive Scandal but I just feel
like I have to do the right thing here
so can we just play the portion of
DeSantis first then we'll play the other
part from the space coast to the
Suncoast from St John's to St Lucie from
the streets of Hialeah to the speedway
in Daytona
from the Okeechobee all the way up to
mikanopi
okay so I heard that portion of the
speech and the Rhythm that it went with
and it was reminding me of something
something from the early 1990s and then
it hit me from the Gulf Coast to the
Atlantic from the keys to the Okefenokee
with the 11 o'clock news this is Jerry
Kennedy
John if it turns out that DeSantis
speechwriter stole from Blanche Deborah
Golden Girls season seven I think it's
episode 2 1992. does this take down the
whole thing absolutely not they lived in
Coral Gables The Golden Girls I think
they were Jeb Bush's neighbors I'm all
in for this go for it Ron take more from
them
Buck would you like to comment on that
before we move to the other stuff oh
sure I I was a was a big Golden Girls
reruns fan back in the day along with
you know Charles in Charge there's like
a whole slate of these shows that I feel
like I was watching in their second run
uh Golden Girls had some great writing
and but you know it is a throwback I did
start I I've seen I haven't seen Golden
Girls since I moved down here but I will
say that I I have watched some Miami
Vice and uh which I never really watched
before and you see what the Florida of
the 80s was like and what it's turned
into now it's a pretty fascinating
transformation
um I still I still tell cardillo that I
want to wear the uh sunglasses with the
yeah that connects and like neon
flip-flops you can do that here and a
pink tank top with an alligator across
it but you know I might do that I'm
gonna rent a Ferrari a convertible
Ferrari buck and I are just gonna go
cruise around that settles it I mean if
let's be honest if any of us went for a
walk on cardillo's boat and he did have
a pet gator would it really be that
surprising
it would not Carol do you have any
thoughts on The Golden Girls a great a
great series of women from Florida yeah
Blanche was the best one too so if
DeSantis is going to lift from any of
them I think she's the one to borrow
from you just kind of you know Dorothy
was kind of a big lib but you knew
Blanche was with us so I think I think
he made the right decision of who to
copy there Dorothy would have been
telling all of her neighbors to to
double mask she would have been
Superstar Dorothy would have voted for
Charlie Chris that's very sad very sad
all right let's shift uh away from
Florida for a second because I mean
every day on the show I say all these
great things about Florida everyone gets
it okay fine but there are some other
things going on in the country and I
guess there are people that live outside
Florida from what I've read uh and DC is
just an absolute uh cluster F right now
of what's going on with the Republicans
being unable to select a leader so we've
got it so this is all Breaking right
this second so we've got a tweet from
Jake Sherman uh breaking news Kevin
McCarthy announces on GOP call that he
and Chip Roy have a deal so I guess
there is some kind of deal but it sounds
like it's tenuous at best it's not
official and obviously they haven't
voted on it yet and Chip Roy is saying
that it's not quite closed
um so first uh well Buck let me go to uh
first on this one what do you make of
just the general state of the fight
because my position is that the fight in
and of itself a couple days of fighting
that's not the worst thing in the world
like let's let's have at it a little bit
right that's been my feeling from the
beginning I've been saying this on on
radio uh what's the big deal these
people are paid to fight over stuff like
this it's fine it's not like we're
missing some great opportunity to pass
amazing legislation when was the last
time that happened anyway and and there
there should be some sense that it's not
always I I think that there are a lot of
people that just they at least want
disruption in the debate if not
disruption uh you know within the GOP if
not disruption in the actual process uh
that goes on and I think they'd like to
see both so I'm I'm fine with it I don't
know like Let Them Fight I also been
telling everybody because you know some
people get a little too uh you know if
you agree with somebody on 95 of
political issues or 90 of political
issues and then you start calling them a
rhino or a squisher or a bad person over
who's gonna be speaker of the house I'm
like where do we think this Republican
primary is going because let's just say
I know there are two heavyweights
everybody thinks about Nikki Haley is
definitely going to be running a few
other people are definitely going to be
running it's going to get a little messy
you know sometimes it's got to be like
Thanksgiving after everyone's had three
glasses of wine you know people are
gonna let it fly a little bit right and
usually you're a little bit of a better
fighter when you fought some better
opponents that's kind of how it works
and don't forget guys just as of this
morning John Bolton and his mustache are
running for president as Republicans but
look I got two clips here so I want to
show you kind of both sides of where uh
the Republicans are at at the moment
first here's chip Roy this is yesterday
when he was calling for the nomination
of Byron Donalds who as uh my audience
knows is a congressman from down here
Southwest Florida so take a look today
I'm rising to nominate Byron Donalds for
Speaker of the House of Representatives
[Applause]
Byron
is
a dear friend
a solid conservative
but most importantly
a family man who loves dearly his wife
Erica
his three children
has a proven track record as a
businessman
Public Service in the Florida
legislature
and now as a member of the United States
Congress
but there's an important reason
for nominating Byron
and that is
this country needs a change
this country needs leadership that does
not reflect
this city
this town that is badly broken
[Applause]
so I think the sentiment is right there
John I'll start with you on this one
um exporting a little bit of what we got
in Florida and I think Byron Donald's is
a great example of that that would be
pretty sweet even though I guess at this
moment it sounds like it's not going to
happen
yeah look Byron Donald's to me is an
absolute rock star they got one of the
best uh public speakers extemporaneous
public speakers I've ever seen he
understands the issues incredibly well
he gets it the man loves America I'd
love to see Byron Donald as a speaker
but chip Roy is right about something
else DC is badly broken and it's a town
that runs on money and Kevin McCarthy
has raised so many members so much money
and I'm getting beat up on Twitter
because I'm like hey look this is kind
of a pointless fight right it's a good
fight to have don't get me wrong but you
can't get everything right now and
here's my fear I don't trust in that in
that group of 200 to 203 depending on
which ballot you're looking at that
voted for Kevin McCarthy and won't waver
I don't trust and it's a bet I would
never take that you don't have six Liz
Cheney's or Adam kinzinger's in there
that if this thing goes long enough are
going to move over cut a deal with Dems
and vote for Hakeem Jeffries because the
part of this world ignoring is on every
vote on on every ballot Hakeem Jeffries
a radical leftist a true communist
Hakeem Jeffries has gotten 212 votes six
more six cheneys or kinzingers move over
we've got the most radically far-leved
Speaker of the House the United States
has ever seen he makes Nancy Pelosi look
like Bill Clinton or a moderate r or
that's my fear so I do want to see this
thing closed quickly I think it's going
to be very difficult for somebody
besides McCarthy to get the votes I just
don't trust today's Republican party you
know the chip Roy's and the Byron
Donalds are anomalies they're they're in
the the vast minority of true
conservatives I don't trust this
conservative this Republican party to
hold the line the Democrats are far
better at the political Bloodsport as it
is today than are Republicans or they
better close the thing quickly or
Jeffries is going to make his move yeah
and just to be clear even though the
Republicans technically have the
majority it could happen they just get
like six guys as you're saying to jump
to the other side and then next thing
you know we we have one party rule again
real quick let me show you the
Counterpoint on this so Dan Crenshaw
who's also from Texas which is
interesting because obviously chip Roy
is a congressman from Texas as well
here's Crenshaw giving the opposing
point on sort of why you should go with
McCarthy we all served in different ways
but we mostly serve for the same reason
so that we would take the fight to the
enemy and the enemy would not no longer
take the fight to the American people we
had purpose we had mission that was our
mission we have Mission up here some
people have different priorities some
people want to cut spending some people
want to fix our mandatory spending
problems some of us want to fix the
Border deal with the Mexican drug
cartels that are murdering tens of
thousands Americans a year by poisoning
them with fentanyl there's a lot of
missions that we have up here I don't
think that the American people care
about any of these so-called missions
happening this week
rules changes who gets more power who
gets on what committee I can't think of
one American who gives a damn about any
of that
they care about the mission
and the conservative agenda is one that
will accomplish the mission for the
American people the best but we can't
start that agenda until we start
governing that's why we're up here
because we care about Mission we care
about service and we care about the
American people we care about getting
things done
Carol what do you think about that take
that it's sort of like suck it up you 20
like we've got the majority it'll be
better than the other guys let's just
play through something to that effect so
so I don't understand the idea that this
is somehow embarrassing that democracy
is embarrassing like oh how embarrassing
that everybody agrees and especially the
left saying it to us like oh how
humiliating you guys don't agree on
everything
um I I hate all of that that's like
ridiculous to me and what I think
Crenshaw is wrong about here is that
Americans do understand what is
happening go to any conservative chat
group on the internet they know what is
happening in Congress they understand
this battle they really do and yes they
want the bigger agenda passed absolutely
but they want the people in charge who
will be most accountable for passing
that agenda and it look there's so many
personality driven things here like the
fact that Trump supports Kevin McCarthy
that's so big in the background of this
like his supporters are like kind of not
going along with what he wants but by
his supporters I mean trumps and they
want somebody new and they also want
somebody held people held accountable
for the the losses that happen in this
last election and they want leadership
change and that's not crazy that's not
embarrassing that's not humiliating and
it's okay that we all are arguing it out
I love by the way I should just add love
that John cardillo is being called a
rhino on Twitter I find that it's
unbelievable I'm a big squish Rhino I'm
being called Dan Crenshaw light that was
one of my favorite I can't even stand
the guy so happy it's that's actually
hilarious it's one thing if I get called
a rhino but cardillo like something
really ain't right the biggest
dissonance I mean this is right up there
with people saying like cardillo he
doesn't go hard in the paint you know
that's not a guy that really throws down
on the right I'm like uh go back go back
at his Twitter feed like a month and
tell me and tell me who else is is
throwing the kind of punches that John
but anyway put that aside for a second
somehow there's just this carve out
where it's fine for Donald Trump to push
for McCarthy and this is where I say to
people come on now come on now if we're
going to do this thing where they're
gonna fillet people on Twitter uh about
how their their squishes and their fakes
and by the way I haven't come I'm I'm a
proud fence sitter on this issue I'm
like look I think there could be a
better speaker I think McCarthy would
probably be more or less you know maybe
with some concessions okay I don't
really care I actually think I agree
with actually a lot of what what
Crenshaw said about how this doesn't
really I agree that it doesn't really
matter I don't think it's fair that
people don't know what's going on but I
don't think it changes all that much
um but the fact that Trump is able to
come out in favor and basically tell
everybody we'll vote for McCarthy and no
one's saying well Trump is a rhino
squish who's a big Trump supporter I
mean that just goes to show you here
that I think people this is about
emoting our side doesn't doesn't do that
very often but after a really
disappointing midterm election
um and after the recognition that we
have look we have fights ahead I mean
that I just think this is the first of
many battles like this where it's not
going to be so clear to everybody what
the agenda should be who should be in
charge of that agenda and the best way
to get it through I I don't believe
there's all this Clarity on the right I
I think people need to throw some elbows
and figure this out yeah we don't do
emoting but we do a lot of personal like
a lot of the the interactions that we
have on the right are personality based
and very very personal I just think that
the left often puts aside differences
and just joins together and we don't do
that we're like I hate that guy he did
something bad to me once in 1986 and
there's no way I'm voting with him and
there's just a lot of that on the right
and I wish we would sort of stop all the
personal kind of feelings like McCarthy
just people just don't like him some
people just don't like him and it has
nothing to do with how good he can pull
together the caucuses or any of that
it's about they just don't personally
don't like him and you see this in the
interviews that they give on TV V it's
like it is personal and I wish we
wouldn't do it it is interesting though
the the Trump portion of this As Trump
has sort of been you know neutered to
where he just posts things on truth that
then get shared elsewhere with his you
know capitalization and and sort of
crazy way of talking where he basically
is backing McCarthy where it seems like
his own base doesn't really like
McCarthy and the guys that he's trying
to convince are not really listening to
him even if there's a deal there so that
might signal a little bit of the the
sort of squandered influence of trump
what do you think John
yeah I mean I got beat up on both sides
right I got beat up for saying that they
should close this thing quickly and then
I put out a tweet the other day
yesterday or the day before saying look
one of the uh one of the stories not
being told is that Trump's political
Capital clearly isn't what it used to be
because to the point of Carolyn buck and
you Dave Trump has been pushing for
McCarthy and pretty hard actually and
behind closed doors from people I know
very close to him even harder and it's
falling on deaf ears Matt Gates is a
trump loyalist in every other respect
but on this he's not budging and he's
not listening to the former president
Trump supporters as Carol noted are not
listening to Trump and so it's it's an
interesting tale about where Trump's
political Capital sits today
who's been on some dates sometimes that
were going well in the past Dave uh and
then the the lady that I was sitting
across from said something that I just
really didn't want to hear about
something right something that was a
little off a little dumb a little weird
you can just pretend you didn't hear it
you know that's one option you sort of
go like I don't think she even said that
thing she said Trump voters are doing
that right now with McCarthy not all of
them like you didn't know good analogy
it didn't actually he didn't say that
thing I still love him it's great it's
fine you're like okay
or the other thing they do the other
thing they say is he's keeping his
enemies closer it's 4D chess which is
just stupid and really really just it's
annoying but you know his followers are
going to make excuses but I I do think
this says quite a bit about where he
stands and it might be telling going
into 24 about his Capital value and it
might be really telling going to 24.
well we can't talk about Trump without
talking about Adam Schiff and Adam
Schiff went on The View and he talked to
Joy bather so do I even have to lead it
with anything other than that they're
going to be blocking Biden's agenda
investigating his family and his cabinet
Hunter Biden's laptop they promised to
kick you off the house intelligence
committee what are you going to do about
that
well you know in terms of my uh my
service on the intelligence committee
this was one of the promises I think
Kevin McCarthy gave one of the great
many that growing lists uh to try to
placate the hardliners like Marjorie
Taylor green and get their support
um but uh but you know there are much
bigger concerns frankly I have with what
they will do
Carol is McCarthy showing up on these
shows particularly The View which has
become a complete caricature of what
Barbara Walters who just passed away
wanted to create you know 20 years ago
is that just a perfect example of what
sort of the swamp and the Machine and
the monster is these people who lie
about everything never get fired never
get called out all of the stuff it just
endlessly happens over and over and
usually they actually just get
promotions out of it or or better TV
gigs so you said McCarthy I'm sure you
mean [ __ ] oh I'm sorry ship [ __ ] so I
maybe I didn't maybe that that might
have been a very uh question got really
interesting with the McCartney although
that would be interesting right
um
it's of course Schiff is just part of
the absolute swamp via swamp but he he
says that like MTG wants to get rid of
him
um and I want to know which Republican
wants to keep Schiff like who is the
Republican who is who would like to have
him stay on so the idea that that it's
some hardliners who are anti-him like no
that's a pretty all all-around idea that
we all share
um that that shift is just the absolute
worst and that he's you know reduced to
talking on The View about his
um plans and how much he hates various
Republicans Buck do you think it's a
good idea so assuming that it is
McCarthy or one way or another the
Republicans are going to get this thing
and it's not going to be Hakeem Jeffries
do you like the idea of just opening up
investigations into everything do you
think that's what people want whether
it's covid or whether it's looking into
the January 6 commission or any of all
the nonsense they've put us through is
that the best use of their time or would
you rather them go in another Direction
it's the thing that they do that they
can do it's not going to make very much
difference
um the the Benghazi effect I think is
where this becomes most apparent uh the
Benghazi hearings look once Barack Obama
won re-election the idea that there was
going to be accountability for Benghazi
to anybody who understands the
bureaucracy I mean I come out of the CIA
right it was laughable it's just not
going to happen there's just no way
because what happens when you look at a
failure like that you have all these
different people who just point the
fingers at 100 other people and no one's
really responsible for anything right
the only accountability comes for the
person at the top whether State
Department or the president and that
didn't happen so it was great for people
to audition for cable news uh shows
after they finish their congressional
terms but it had no actual effect
whatsoever
um I think that you are likely to see
uh some of these investigation the the
one the one where I would say it's
different because we really do need the
information more information is on
anything coveted and vaccine related
um on on that data internally because
that fight as we all know is still going
on to convince more people of how wrong
the fauci Democrat side was on this and
also how dishonest they were so I'm in
favor of getting that information out
there so I'm not saying it's useless but
this idea that we're going to have
hearings and hold them accountable
accountability Comes The Ballot Box I
mean the other side will start are we
going to get a special counsel no do
they ever appoint special counsels no
does anyone really think they're going
to prosecute Hunter Biden clay and I
have a bet on that one I already won but
we're gonna do another bet on that one
you know once you understand the nature
of these people in this Machinery you
know where it's all going so you know
investigations it'll give us something
to talk about on the covet side I think
the information is necessary to get on
the public sphere but we're not going to
own the libs by having a bunch of
members of Congress you know have some
terse questioning sessions it's just not
going to happen yeah I I agree with that
and and John isn't it interesting
because not only okay we have these
investigations nothing really goes
anywhere but I don't know if you guys
have noticed this the last couple days
on Twitter but there have been a ton of
ads from uh HHS and the CDC where their
messaging on kovit has significantly
changed they are now saying stuff on
Twitter that a year ago would have
gotten all all of us banned basically
saying if you're under 50 and young and
healthy you don't need the vaccine
that's what their ads are saying because
they're trying to get older people vaxed
if we would have said that a year ago we
would have been booted so they they it's
not just that the investigations don't
do anything they actually change their
narrative in real time so you completely
forget all of the stuff that they
botched all along
yeah absolutely and the Bucks excuse me
Buck is spot on right Congress has no
prosecutorial power they've got to send
it up to the attorney general Merrick
Garland is waging a campaign of
Retribution and reprisal against
conservatives for killing his scotus bid
so that's the last guy who's going to do
anything look I the last clip you played
gave me an idea let's just sit fouchy in
a room and make him listen to Behar and
Chef having a conversation all day that
is [ __ ] I bet you wish you had that back
in the agency for the Taliban I mean
that was torturous having a listen to
that that's worse than waterboarding
worse than waterboarding but look I
agree with buck get the information out
there because the one thing we need to
do is have doctors even Bill Maher uh
there was a clip on Twitter today of
Bill Maher saying doctors are afraid his
doctors tell him very different things
in private than they're willing to say
in public let's get this information out
there so doctors are no longer afraid to
speak publicly and give their patients
the proper advice on these vaccines and
I think if anything comes out of any
hearings and that's the thing then we
took a step forward
well speaking of other screwy government
things uh Joe Biden finally finally he's
talking about the Border I think he's a
little confused about this title 42
situation take a look in fact the
previous administration used a rule
called title 42 to deal with to deal
with the pandemic a rapidly to rapidly
expel people who cross the border it was
designed to deal with a pandemic but
it's used as a means to expel people at
the border people turned away under
title 42 and there are not and and and
and they're not barred from trying to
come back they've been turned away they
go back they try again they try again
well you know they can and they do try
to re-enter the United States again and
again which makes the problem that
borders at the border even worse
man is it just me or is it getting
harder and harder to listen to him
because he has no idea what he's saying
actually about two minutes after that he
turned to Kamala and called her
president Harris and you could see that
when they locked eyes the shame in her
face of this absolute farce uh Carol
they're not going to do anything on the
border right like they just want more
and more people to come the other thing
that he announced was he's going to give
these people an app or access to an app
so that they can get in line in effect
he also compared the migrant situation
below our Southern border uh to the
Holocaust which probably not the really
most apt comparison right especially
because he did add don't come to the
border to be coming so like at the
Holocaust would hear it like don't come
do not get on the ships
um you know it's so just
um disheartening to me that Republicans
will not fight on the border it is such
a popular issue to stop the flow of
illegal immigration at our Southern
border and I just continue not to
understand why Republicans won't make it
a political issue it is not racist it is
not in any way racist it is it is
absolutely about the rule of law and you
know I say this of course as an
immigrant as somebody who had to wait to
come into the United States as a refugee
and I don't understand why Republicans
won't use it last month Chuck Schumer
said that he wants to legalize every
single person in the U.S legally not
like dreamers who are brought here with
kids no every single person and yet that
wasn't used in ads in Georgia for the
Herschel Walker runoff um that would
have been a really powerful ad and so I
we could blame Biden and we can blame
down democrats for the mess continuing
mess but until Republicans step up and
grow a pair and start fighting on this
it won't change we're just going to
continue to have this flow Buck are we
missing something on the media side of
this thing I mean you probably saw last
week they had this video out of the El
Paso Airport with just you know dozens
and dozens if not hundreds of illegal
aliens just sleeping at the airport and
it's like nobody's gonna cover that on
mainstream media you know we showed it
you probably talked about it but it
never bubbles up and because of that the
average person doesn't have a freaking
clue what's going on and then they hear
Chuck Schumer say make everyone legal
and it sounds nice and people are stupid
like it's basically something like that
we talk about it but I think we also
sometimes on the right get pulled down
into the weeds of oh well it's title 42
and they're going to change and they're
going to do some shifting of resources
to they want as many illegals to come
into the country as possible yes they
want to legalize all of the illegals all
of them who are in the country they want
to make it illegal to call them illegals
uh the moment that you actually look at
the reality of policy I've been to the
Border many times I've spent a lot of
time down there with border patrol and
and the the amount the the sheer volume
of the scams that are constantly being
run these are not Asylum Seekers this is
the whole thing well so we sit here
talking about oh how do we process the
Asylum Seekers Carol talked about coming
here as a refugee Refugee Supply in a
foreign country to come into this
country because of clear oppression from
a tyrannical government it's not a
tyrannical government if you just want
access to a better jobs Market or better
welfare that's not the same thing people
that are leaving countries that have
gang violence we have gang violence lots
of countries have gang violence that
doesn't make you an asylum Seeker they
use the system to get into the country
and then they don't actually show up for
their hearings they and if they do show
up for the hearings there's usually an
additional hearing about deportation we
have to start talking about what we're
going to really do not just stop people
from coming in now but also are we going
to do are we going to remove people or
encourage self-deportation to people who
have come in recent years in this flood
of of now 5 million under Biden so I
think Republicans talk about it but they
don't
they're sort of using the the framework
of the Democrats of oh well it's border
security let's look no this is a mass
illegal immigration plan that has been
playing out really for decades but
accelerated dramatically in the last
four years and Democrats lie about it at
every step and at every stage they are
absolutely full of crap am I allowed to
curse on the show you can say crap you
you can go further than crap if you'd
like you're a radio guy so if you really
want to drop it this is your moment yeah
I was like you know the city would be
like this is Malarkey's cockamami what's
going on yes and by the way just to add
to what you said even if they were all
fleeing the most horrific repression and
and all of the worst stuff that we can
all imagine that's not a reason for us
not to have a border we still should
have a border that's protected and then
figure out how to number of real Asylum
Seekers as it is right I mean if if a
hundred million people in China said we
all want to come here because the
Chinese Communist party's totalitarian
Chinese Communist party is totalitar
Aryan but America is not America if 100
million foreigners show up in one year
like we all I know people say well
that's crazy yeah and how crazy is it
getting these days five in two years is
going to keep going right and look
Bernie Sanders made that point one time
he said if you open the borders you
cannot imagine the level of poverty
around the world and how many people are
going to come here Bernie Sanders I mean
you know it's not a crazy idea people
will come here well that's because
Bernie knows he doesn't want to give up
one of the three houses to these uh
these immigrants John since people are
calling you a rhino on Twitter bring us
home here really go full crazy right I
mean look extremist I'm gonna go full
crazy right-wing extremely by the way
but listen it's through the lens of
pragmatism I've been chomping at the bit
over the last 48 hours if you've been
watching some of these videos the
Mexican Army launched a full-blown
military assault in kuyacan now A
kuyacan is for those who don't know it's
the home of miles and bada well who is
he Ismail Mayo zimbata was El Chapo's
partner he was real El Chapo's padron
his his Godfather is Rabbi the guy that
got him started in the cocaine game in
the drug trafficking game you hear my
dog barking because uh he somehow got
out but they caught El Chapo they called
El Chapo's son well those sicarios those
killers that work for the cartels are
now fleeing like little rats and like
fleas where are they going they're going
to come here and what are they going to
do now this isn't speculative this isn't
cardillo Lex law enforcement guy being a
fear Monger this is what happens talk to
anybody at ice talk to anybody at
Homeland Security investigations anybody
at DEA DEA intelligence South of the
Border they're going to tell you these
guys come here and where do they go they
go to Miami they go to Texas to Houston
to Dallas really go to Chicago New York
Los Angeles they align with MS-13 with
the Mexican Mafia and the drug gangs
that are already murderers that are
already vicious that already flooding
the streets with synthetic meth by the
way everybody worries about cocaine and
Fentanyl as as it's analyzed right now
Dean intelligence feels that the mile
zimbata has somewhere in the
neighborhood of six to eight billion
dollars in synthetic meth in tunnels in
Mexico ready to bring into the U.S so
these sicarios come up here they create
these drug networks these more vicious
killer gangs they build those tunnels if
you think drugs are flooding the streets
now
just wait until we really see the
effects of Biden's policies this will
get Americans killed make no mistake
brutal deaths from either being shot in
crossfires or horrific drug overdoses
it's getting police officers killed it's
getting kids killed the Biden
Administration is committing felony upon
felony they'll never be held to account
but they should be
I cannot end the show on a Friday with
brutal death and mass drug overdosing so
can you ask for it well no I'm going to
let Carol finish this up but Buck you've
got a just enough of a smile there that
I feel you can get us out of that mess
and then I'm gonna have Carol bring us
home say something nice before the
weekend for God happy happy one year
January 6th anniversary again I you know
we get to be Floridians we get to go out
in the sunshine I'm gonna spend the
weekend at the beach I don't know what
the rest of you usually cardillo does
these you know these hits from the beach
so I think
yeah thank you for doing this indoors
this weekend
um we're lucky we're blessed oh you know
what I wanted to add that my favorite
part of Rhonda Santos's speech is you
know again I'm an immigrant I'm a super
America lover and I love the part where
he said that we have to fight for this
country and we can't just be like oh
America's over that's it what are you
gonna do I hate that I think I love that
we're fighting I love that the fight it
starts in Florida and there's nowhere
else to go we have to fight for this
place let's do it yeah well I enjoy
fighting with you guys Buck I will give
you the final word Carol stuck The
Landing I'm gonna go out into my 80
degree weather and drink something made
with fruit with a little umbrella in it
because Florida
amen going to the beach club guys let's
do it all right have a great weekend
guys uh I'm gonna continue for a few
minutes we are jumping over to our
locals exclusive post game show where
you guys can correct me on anything that
I screwed up you can say all sorts of
mean things about my guests and much
more
reubenreport.locals.com so we're going
to jump over right now you guys have a
great weekend enjoy your fruity drinks
and all that good stuff and uh are we
pausing for a moment or am I just
rolling right in
we're gonna go right into locals all
right all right see you guys thank you
are you still monitoring the speakers
right
are you still watching
attention attention
[Music]
foreign
[Music]